My name is Becca Krouse.
I am a data scientist at GSK in
our statistics and data science
innovation hub, where my team
is working on building support
systems and facilitating
the adoption of R
across biostatistics.
Today I'll be talking about R
package assessment lessons that
can be learned from pharma.
In today's world,
we have no shortage
of products right
at our fingertips
that can be received in
just days or even hours
with the click of a mouse.
Vendors of all shapes and
sizes have the ability
to reach consumers
across the globe, which
means as consumers,
we have a wide variety
of features to choose from, but
also quite a range of quality.
Sound familiar?
Whether you're
looking for something
you need on Amazon or
a package on CRAN,
you probably want
to find something
that suits your needs
that you can count on.
So what?
How do you make those decisions?
What do you look for?
You're probably going
to look at indicators
that you feel are important.
So if you think about how
you approach online shopping,
you probably go to the
reviews, the ratings, badges,
the name of the seller.
And depending on what
you're looking for,
how much time you
have, maybe you
deep dive into those reviews.
While the indicators, and
I'll say the indicators
give you an overall
picture of confidence
of whether the product is
going to look, feel, and perform
as advertised.
While the indicators
are a little bit
different for packages, the
overall idea is the same.
A little bit of
research is going
to go a long way to build
that picture of confidence
that the package is going
to produce results that you
can count on that are accurate.
Now, this idea is absolutely
critical to those of us in
I mean, it doesn't
matter your work,
but it's especially
critical to those of us
in regulated
industries like pharma,
where it's really
important for us
to deliver safe and
effective drugs to patients
as quickly as we can.
And to do so, we need to make
sure our data and our analysis,
our entire pipelines are free
of errors and full of integrity.
A huge part off of our
pipelines is the software
that's used to produce the
results, transform the data,
all that type of stuff.
We we really want
to do our research,
and the regulators expect
that we do our due diligence
and make defensible choices.
So regulators expect that
our choices are defensible,
meaning that we want
to do our due diligence
and provide sufficient
documentation of why we feel
that our software, our
packages, work correctly
and produce correct results.
So let's think about
that for a minute.
How do we really know
our results are correct?
Well, one thing we
can do is compare
against a source of truth.
That source of truth could
be your common sense,
another programmer, another
programming language,
maybe a publication
like a textbook, even.
And this is true
regardless of whether using
the latest and greatest R
package or a SAS proc that's
been around for decades.
It's all the same
idea, and we want
to make sure that our results
are going to be accurate
for many scenarios we
haven't encountered yet.
Many new data sets,
new studies in the future.
We're in exciting
times now and pharma
is making progress full speed
ahead towards R
Being a primary tool used in
studies and submission work.
Folks across the industry are
putting their heads together
to align on a common
philosophy for what
it takes to ensure
that our R packages are
accurate. In the R validation hub,
specifically, this philosophy
focuses on a package assessment,
and there's some principles
and some ideas in place,
but it's up to the
individual organizations
to then implement
it for themselves
and really decide how
much evidence is enough.
At GSK, where we're working
hard on our own implementation
and we've settled on a set of
guiding principles for how we
think about package assessment.
And I'll present
those to you today
as the domains of
trustworthiness.
There's five of them.
Each one plays an important
role in the overall assessment.
And each one consists of
a collection of things.
Those things are sometimes quite
easy to measure, quantifiable.
But others are a little bit
more nuanced, harder to measure,
more subjective.
So let's step through these now.
Beginning with the
Community domain.
The purpose of this domain is to
get an idea of how broadly used
a package is in the community,
how much folks are enjoying it,
how strong its roots are.
So specifically, we can look
at something like downloads
to get an idea of the
volume of use to date.
And that volume of
use is an indicator
of how much the
package has been vetted
in real life scenarios, how
much it's been stress tested.
We are also interested in the
overall trajectory of that use.
Is it gaining traction?
Is the package maintaining
or declining for some reason?
Maybe there's another
package that's come along
that's superseded it.
We also want to look at
how the community relates
to the package and
its maintainers.
Both how the community
relies on this package,
depends on this package
as part of other software,
or other materials like books.
And also going the
opposite direction,
How much the package maintainer
has a vested interest
in supporting the
community and keeping up
with the ever-evolving many
moving parts of the community.
Now something to keep in mind
is in an industry like pharma,
we have some fairly
specific needs.
Maybe our packages
that we are choosing
are a little more niche, or
we have some internal packages
that we're using.
So by nature these are going
to have a little bit smaller
community user base,
and that's OK.
We have other domains
to look at as well.
With the Authorship domain.
We are doing some research to
learn who the developers are,
what are their backgrounds,
their experience,
and really does that experience,
is that an appropriate match
for the complexity of the tool?
We found this one to
be fairly important
for statistical packages
where that level of expertise
is quite high, quite specific.
So some things
that we look at here
are the overall reputation, how the
community regards this author
as an expert in their
field, as an R developer,
and how much experience they
have in both those areas.
So something you can look
at is the other packages
that that person or those individuals
might have out there.
And any specific qualifications,
degrees, certificates,
things like that, all
round out our picture
of who these authors are and
what their backgrounds are.
And this domain is
quite dependent on what
you can find out there,
which obviously varies
from individual to individual.
So, it's important nonetheless.
Our next domain is the
Documentation domain,
which here I intend to cover
functionality documentation.
So what is the tool
supposed to do?
What is the intent, and
What is the scope?
What are the limits of that
tool to help us understand
what is appropriate use?
What is responsible use?
This is kind of a prerequisite
to being able to prove
accuracy.
You need to understand
in which cases your function
is going to produce
correct results.
So documentation
we are all probably
pretty familiar
with looking around
at help files,
vignettes, examples.
So what we're after is,
do those things exist?
But also what is their quality?
How helpful and clear are they?
What types of
scenarios are covered?
And then for the intended
use, clear documentation
of expected inputs.
Expected outputs.
Really nice.
If edge case, the limits
piece is covered in there.
What what
What might we want to
watch out for when we're
using this tool, for instance?
And this leads us into the
Software Development Life Cycle
domain, which we are
aiming to capture
the overall process for how
the code develops and evolves
over time, how it is
cared for, essentially.
With this one,
first and foremost,
we need transparency
into what's happening.
And luckily for us, this is
increasingly easy with things
like GitHub, which is
pretty popular these days,
it allows us to get a
peek into what's going on,
what kind of branching
model is being
used, how are things being
worked on and merged in,
and are there any
What is the roadmap of the tool?
Are there any
critical open issues?
All things we can look
at just by peeking
into that repository.
And to get a sense
of how well supported
it is, we can also look at the
activity, how quickly the code
or how often the code
is being worked on.
Issues being closed.
Releases to CRAN.
And then any safeguards
that are in place
to protect the integrity
of the code as it evolves.
Protected branches,
continuous checking,
continuous testing,
all to prevent
against any bugs being
introduced as this changes.
Now something to keep
in mind is a package
could have all the hallmarks
of a good package here.
But maybe it's
really, really new
and it hasn't had a chance
to work out some of the bugs.
And, you know, we're
not aware of those yet.
And it hasn't been
stress tested enough yet
or it's changing a lot.
On the other end of
things, a package
could have fairly
stalled development,
which could mean
it's been abandoned
or it could mean it's just
really, really stable.
So something to keep in mind
and looking at this domain
is what is the history
of the project?
Where is it in terms
of its lifecycle?
And our final domain
is the Testing domain.
So here, testing, I
mean, the actual testing
inside the package,
oftentimes this is your test
that your unit tests.
And what these do is check
that the functionality
is working as expected and that
it's producing correct results.
Which sounds a lot like
our definition of accuracy
that we talked about earlier.
So a really solid test suite can
be essentially a gold standard
for how you can prove accuracy.
So let's take a look
at what we might
look for inside the package.
So this is your
package directory,
but we can look at
whether a test exists
and what they're covering.
So things like code
coverage, which
which functions are being
covered and to what extent.
And from there, we
can look specifically
at what we're
interested in, what are
the key things that we feel
we are going to
be using the most?
And how deep that
testing is on those.
So what types of scenarios
are covered there?
What types of inputs
are the developers
looking for and are they
comparing against some known
value?
Even better if that
source of truth
comes from some
outside resource.
Now I recognize this is
a fairly technical task,
so this may look a little
bit different depending
on who you are and what
resources you have.
But even being familiar
with the first two,
the presence, the depth, sorry,
the presence, the breath,
and then taking a
peek into the depth,
maybe like some of those
descriptions in the test, that
can be very helpful.
Another thing to keep in
mind about the testing domain
is not everything is
super easy to test.
Sometimes visualizations
or complex algorithms
can be a little
bit--really novel
complex algorithms can be a
little bit tougher to test.
So that's OK.
It's just, you know, again, we
have the rest of the domains.
So, with those in mind.
The assessment may look a
little bit different depending
on who you are and what you do.
For us, we are very much working
towards R for submission
work. We're very risk
averse in this situation.
We do a pretty
in-depth assessment.
So if you're just kind of
poking around exploring,
maybe you do a little bit
lighter of assessment.
But getting to know your
packages is really important
and it will serve you well.
Also on a task level, if you're
transforming the data,
changing the data in some way
or performing a
statistical analysis,
the stakes might be a little bit
higher if something goes awry.
As compared to.
And also it might be harder
to tell when something
goes awry as compared
to something that's
more aesthetic in nature.
So again, your approach
to the assessment
might change depending on that.
And so you could also
perform this whole assessment
and not be quite satisfied
with the results.
But maybe you have
only one option
and this is the
package you need.
So maybe you're willing to
bend a little bit on your risk
and build some extra safeguards
around that for yourself.
Augment it with some
testing or extra QC.
So even if you find yourself
in the left side very much
in the stable, risk averse,
the rest of the ecosystem
is going to continue
to evolve and change.
And that's the
beauty of R, right?
There's cutting edge, newer
things every single day.
So it's important for us,
if we are in that situation,
to keep our eyes up ahead of
what's to come and find ways
to innovate, find
ways to experiment
and keep our minds open for
any gems that come along.
And we can in turn then grow
our tried and true collection
of packages that we count on.
All right.
So I said there
were five domains,
but I'm going to throw
you one more, which
is the domain about
thinking holistically.
So when we do these
assessments, we
are not expecting a
perfect score by any means.
The packages--the
purpose of the assessment
is to allow these packages to
shine where they are strong
and let those strengths
or weaknesses guide us
in the rest of our
assessment and help
us focus in on what matters.
So for instance, a package
could have really strong tests,
but maybe not as much community
support or vice versa.
So these things can kind of
counter each other, right?
So if we're flexible and
adaptable in our approach,
then we can more effectively
collect that body of evidence
that's going to inform
our sense of trust
in this wonderfully
imperfect open source world.
Thank you.